hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man bar
from home director Jon Watts confirmed
to us on Twitter that in our recent duck
hunt for his missing spider-man
homecoming Howard the Duck Easter Egg we
correctly spotted it well sort of like I
found the right visual clue in the movie
but interpreted it in slightly the wrong
direction so I thought I'd do a quick
follow up to further explain what
exactly the Easter Egg is and what
exactly it's referencing and if you
haven't already go check out my first
breakdown because in addition to finding
the Howard the Duck reference in our
rewatch of homecoming we found a bunch
of other cool stuff that we missed the
first time around okay so quick reminder
recently while promoting far from home
Watts revealed that a Howard the Duck
Easter egg had still gone undiscovered
in homecoming it's like almost so
obscure that I don't even know if anyone
could ever find it but there's a Howard
the Duck reference it's very small so I
took Watts challenge sacrificed several
good hours of sleep and of writing my
own screenplay that I'll never get
finished
we watched homecoming about three times
until I realized that Watts has the
thing with license plates and his
spider-man movies and then finally I
found it on the ferry one cars license
plate reads htd zero zero three now at
first I assumed this was a nod to Howard
the Duck issue three back in 1976 in
which Howard masters quack boo Watts
tweeted back at our video saying close
but not quite but that the license plate
was right yes and with many of your help
specifically you Alex 1976 we have
narrowed down which comic this license
plate was probably referencing the
correct issue is chip sidarskys 2015
Howard the Duck 0:03
in which a variant cover shows Howard
writing these same exact Orange Staten
Island Ferry where this scene with Peter
takes place in homecoming in this issue
Aunt May and spider-man both appear
along with spider-ham and many other
Marvel heroes it's very funny I highly
recommend it so with this corrected
and again check out part 1 of this duck
hunt rewatch and our full homecoming
easter egg break down because 2017 Eric
BOTS was just so young and hopeful that
he would have sold his post-apocalyptic
Florida action comedy features script by
now yeah follow me on Instagram and
Twitter ante a vos its subscribed into
rock stars for hunts of every Easter Egg
everywhere because movies are impossible
to enjoy the other way